the interactive compression to entropy
which is based partially based
on a joint work with a balthazar bower
from ens leon
and with amelio dioff from the technion
okay so
compression is a pretty general theme
that we see
in many fields of science and
even philosophy we have a occam razor
which roughly says that simpler is
better we have einstein's response
einstein's warning that you shouldn't
make things too simpler
in computer science we also
have compression
actually in the past six months we've
been studying a beautiful notion of
compression in machine learning
but but in this talk we'll focus about
compression of conversations of
interactive communication which
generalizes the
the basic uh transmission problem the
one-way communication which was studied
by shannon
so here is a conversation
which is really easy to compress
so this is a i don't know 16 15 rounds
conversation and we can compress it only
to two rounds
and you know my sister actually when you
converse with her
so she begins with a pretty long prefix
of this
protocol
but at least you get the feeling that
she really cares about you which maybe
you cannot quantify with information
so
okay
so the way we model conversations is
with the
yao
communication complexity from 79
i will not
i will not talk much about it because we
all know it and we've seen it in
previous lectures
but just maybe a notational note is that
we will use m sub pi
to denote the transcript of the protocol
so if pi
is a deterministic protocol m sub pi is
the leaf which corresponds to the input
so m supply depends on x and y on the
input
okay
so what is compression means we when we
want to formalize the the notion of
compression
there are two things we need to
to deal with two formulas to quantify
the first one is how do we measure
information
and there are several ways to do it and
we will discuss
four of them
and the second one is what does it mean
that the simulating protocol preserves
the content of the simulated protocol
and this we capture by defining what a
stimulation means and we will see two
ways
of doing that
so let's begin with uh discussing how we
measure information
so the the standard
um
quantifications that were introduced by
in this form at least i think by
bbcr
um
is the external information the internal
information
so we assumed the input of the protocol
is drawn from some distribution mu
um and we define these quantities using
the mutual information from from
information theory
so the external information
which i think we haven't discussed yet
in this workshop
is just the mutual information between
the transcript and the inputs and the
intuitive semantic of it is the number
of bits that an external observer lands
on the input
from the transcript
so there's an external observer he just
sees the conversation and what does he
tell him
on average about the
about the input
the internal information which we have
seen in the previous talk and yesterday
also
is uh also defined with the mutual
information function and
the intuitive semantic is how much
information do the parties get on each
other's input from the transcript
okay so let's consider
perhaps simpler notions of information
which we also denote by external entropy
and internal entropy of analogy to the
information
so the external entropy is simply the
entropy of the transcript
and
given the semantic of entropy what it
means is the number of bits required to
assign the transcript to an external
observer
and we also define the internal entropy
which is the number of bits required to
describe this transcript to the parties
so this term describe how many bits
we need to
to
send alice in order to describe
transceived and the other one is for bob
and in this talk we will focus on this
on these measures
but before we proceed to definition of
simulations let's compare these measures
to the
standard information measures
so
it is not hard to see that the entropies
are always at least
greater or equal than the information so
the external entropy is at least the
external information and the internal
entropy is at least the internal
information
and it's also not so hard to see that
both so after the entropies are lower
bound than the communication
so in this sense um
the entropies are tighter lower bounds
okay
um
the internal information satisfies the
direct sum and this makes it
particularly attractive from the
communication complexity
uh context
we don't know of a
direct sum that is satisfied by any of
the other measures only the internal
information is known to
satisfy this strong direct sum
a manifestation of
of
the importance of direct sum in the
context of communication complexity
is a result of babaman and draw that
internal information equals amortized
communication
external entropy and take maximum
overall transcripts
there is a
there is a fixed distribution
because here
is it's defined
related to some transcript
your entropy is so there is a
distribution there is a distribution in
the input
and then the transcript is a random
variable right
but there is
some protocol right
there is a protocol there is a
distribution input and then you feed the
protocol with the input they communicate
and you got a random variable which is
the transcript the entropy of this
random variable is the external
information the external endo
okay
and similarly for the
protocol is fixed here
is fixed here
there is no function only protocol
okay
yeah so we were here
okay so maybe one last comment is that
if you consider protocols that have no
private randomness then the entropy
measures and the information measures
are the same in fact the same thing
and this is another motivation to study
the entropy measures
is that it may help us understand the
role of private randomness
uh
with in with respect to information
and now
in this talk all protocols will be
deterministic
will make things simpler so a thermistic
protocol is a tree
and
there will be no randomness
okay so
we discussed about four different ways
to measure information let us now see
two different ways to define simulation
yes so in compression we have two things
we want to to shorten the particle but
we want to preserve the content what
does it mean to preserve the content
so we distinguish between external
simulation and internal simulation in an
external simulation intuitively what
happens is that an external observer who
just sees the transcript who just sees
the leaf in the simulating protocol
can in fair format
the leaf of the simulated protocol
so we have sigma we say that sigma
is an external simulation of pi if there
is a mapping from the leaves of sigma to
the leaves of p this is the dictionary
of the of the external observer
such that for a typical input this
mapping is correct it takes it takes us
to the right
leaf in the protocol of pi
so this is
an external simulation
and
we similarly define internal simulation
the difference is that in an internal
simulation
an external observer is not guaranteed
to answer to to understand
the transcript of pi but
the parties themselves
should answer so the dictionary there
are two dictionaries one for alice one
for bob
and the dictionaries again brings us
from leaves of sigma to x of pi but the
dictionary of alice depends on
everything that she knows
which is the transcript of sigma and x
and similarly the dictionary of bob
depends on what he knows
and it is not so hard to cook examples
for which there is a
internal simulation of size 0 but any
external simulation should take
k bits for nk
so
ok so
so so
now this is some kind of evidence that
our definitions make some sense
yeah so what does it say so
here we see if sigma
externally zero arrow simulates pi
then the communication of sigma
is at least the external entropy of pi
and we have a similar statement for
internal simulation so this is an analog
of
of the cl of the
you know the entropy is a lower bound
for any prefix free encoding
but it's an interactive analog of that
and the natural question is whether
these lower bounds are tight or not
okay so let's
so let's first consider the external
simulation
so
huffman call tell us that if pi is a
protocol in which only ali speaks so bob
is passive and alice
sends a message to bob
then we know that huffman coding
is
an external zero simulation of pi that
uses at most one more than the lower
bound
right and we know that also it's optimal
huffman coding
now what happens if we allow interaction
so
there is a result by
it will be hard beats will be wonderlish
that uh that says that even even in the
even in the in the interactive case
uh it is possible so for every protocol
pi and distribution view there exists a
zero error simulation sigma
which is a constant
times the lower bound the obvious lower
bound of the external entropy
and i just showed now that ayal
had a conversation with freya and this
2.18 constant can be improved
i didn't finish the calculations but
what i got is 1.82 but it can be brought
less i'm pretty sure i'm sure
okay so
i will say that at least twice more in
this talk so you can
you can ambush me
okay so uh so this is the external
compression
2006 i think or 2007.
okay so it's uh
we will see the proof it's quite uh
intuitive and simple
okay so
what happens for internal compression so
for the external compression we saw the
the picture is pretty well understood
in intel compression unfortunately we
don't have
such complete understanding in
particularly for epsilon equals zero if
we allow no error then in general it is
impossible to compress
so we must allow error i don't want to
get into the zero error case
so but the point is that we must a low
error
and then there is uh
this result it was proved by several
outers
that we can always
simulate pi with sigma that has
communication
roughly the internal entropy times log
of the communication of pi
so unfortunately we have this
term here this that depends on the
communication of pi and the depth of the
tree
and we in some sense improve this result
by improving the dependency on
the communication of pi to
log log
but we pay an extra multiplicative
factor
of entropy
and as a correlation we get also some
trade-off between private and public
randomness
um
for information which is built on the
protocol that gilad showed yesterday but
i will not get into it i want to
i want to proceed to the proof
okay so
let's first it will be very useful to
first consider the proof of uh
digital milligram and wonderless
that
yeah of this statement
so we are given a deterministic protocol
pi
and we want to simulate it with zero
error we want to construct a protocol
sigma with zero error stimulates pi
and the communication communication of
sigma should be roughly the entropy of
pi
so the idea like in all of the
compression schemes that i at least know
of is to be greedy we want to
communicate two bits
and to convey a constant amount of
information
communicate not too many bills and to
convey constant amount of information
and
so this is the idea
so uh
the essential notion here is of a
meaningful vertex
so we have the protocol pi
and we know that for every vertex v in
the tree of pi
the set of all inputs
whose transcript goes through this
vertex is a rectangle
in particular we know that for rectangle
we can decide with only two bits whether
x and y lie in the rectangle or not ali
should check her part and bob he's about
so what is a meaningful vertex a
meaningful vertex is a vertex which is
balanced
it means that mu of with rectangle is
between exactly one half between
one-third and two-thirds
or
it is a fat leaf
it is a leaf and the measure of a
certain grid is at least two-thirds
so a meaningful vertex is either a
balanced vertex or a fat leaf
and this
simple lemma says that there always is a
meaningful vertex
okay and
it's very similar to how we balance
formulas and balance balance
protocols
now how do we use the existence of a
meaningful vertex
to to finish the proof of
this philippines and wunderlis
so what is how the stigma works so first
without any communication the agreement
of vertex v which is meaningful they
communicate two bits
to determine whether x y
lies in the rectangle of v
and they update mu accordingly by
conditioning on the answer whether xy is
there or not and what we say is that the
entropy of the new mu so we have that
multiple prime will reduce by constant
amount
and
yeah so either there was a leaf in the
simulation is over or they learned the
conditioned on a on an event which has
not not a big probability and we learned
at least 0.5 bits of information
and that's it that's the result of
so
if you follow the calculations you will
get this result
but remember that our objective was to
to to do it for internal entropy
so for internal simulation
now a natural question is whether we can
define a meaningful vertex in this case
also but now we don't have one mu now
the if you remember the the the
definition of internal entropy we have h
of pi given x plus h of pi given y
so in this case
we have two distributions a
distributions from ali's perspective
which is conditioned on her input on
what she knows and its distribution from
bob's perspective which is conditions on
his input what he knows
so alice
has some meaningful vertex v sub a with
respect to mu x
and bob has some vertex v sub b
with respect to mu y
now
simple so here is a nice drawing we did
last night so this is va and this is vb
and
yeah
so so the the simple observation is that
let's assume that both of them both of
them could agree on va
then i claimed that they could
communicate two bits of information
updates their distributions accordingly
and alice if they both knew va so alice
would learn at least 0.5 bits
so if both of them uva or both of them
uvb they could communicate two bits
and proceed
but the problem is that alice knows only
va
she doesn't know vb and bob knows only
vb doesn't know va
so how do we deal with this uh with this
problem
so the observation is that it is enough
that we will agree on a vertex v which
separates vi and vb what does it mean
v for instance is an ancestor of v a and
v is not an ancestor of v b
or vice versa of course
yeah so for example
this vertex is an ancestor
of va and it isn't an ancestor of vb
and why if they could agree on such a
vertex
then they could communicate two bits
and decide whether to jump to this
vertex or not and in either case one of
the parties would learn
a constant amount of information
so for example if they could communicate
two bits
and they decided not to jump to this
vertex
then
they in particular they will not jump to
va and alice will learn a constant
amount of information and if they will
jump to this vertex then bob would learn
a constant amount of information
and
and by the way this observation was also
implicit in in previous compressions and
the way it was typically solved there
was by finding the deepest common
ancestor of bmv the the youngest common
ancestor
which is this guy
and this was done via the protocol of
finding the first difference of fiber at
all which typically cost so finding the
first difference between k bit strings
cos log k
so that was the log cc of the previous
compressions
we observed that if you relax it
and
you you're willing to settle for any
vertex which separates
v a and v b in this sense then you can
do it faster yeah you can do it in
the entropy times log log cc so here we
save algorithmic factor
and it is not the protocol to do it the
the way we do it is not so simple i will
not get into it but i will just mention
that it uses uh
the protocol of phi gapi gagavan and
upfal for finding the further difference
and the variant of sampling
from brahman and rao
but
maybe the message here is that we have
really uh almost a self-contained
problem alice has some vertex va bob has
some vertex vb and they want to find the
vertex to separate them
and what is the fastest way you can do
it
so if you can do it faster than us you
will in particularly get a better
compression
so it's also i don't know in some
intuitive
way complete
okay so
so that's it
so
let's summarize so we defined a couple
of meaning for more than a couple
actually
four meanings for uh
for compressing the conversations
we saw the optimal external compression
of
this filmmaking wonderlish
and we saw an efficient internal
compression
and
i just mentioned that we still do not
have a complete understanding we don't
so i don't know whether this loglog cc
is needed whether we can
we can
make something that only depends on the
entropy
yes and
that's it
so can you
can you please explain what happens if
you try to carry out this approach when
there's a private round
so can you repeat the question so yeah
so when we asks is whether we can
uh carry out this approach for the when
you also have private randomness and
then you don't consider the entropies
but you use the you consider the
internal information that was discussed
earlier so i think it will improve
something but not but uh but it so you
know in the internal you have the square
the square root of i times c let's say
it's time log c c so you can
remove the log c to log log c c times
something maybe but the square root of i
will still remain
the analog of the
meaningful
ah so they're also right there they look
for a cut on the there is a meaningful
cut because they now it's more sampling
problem
so there's no meaning for vertex because
here we assume deterministic
so you have a meaningful cut but they
also they follow the same approach right
you look for min for cut you sample a
vertex in this cut and you proceed it's
it's
oh maybe i'm not cutting
suppose you want to get uh
external square times low block cc
for the general case where you do have
private routers
okay
viable we communicate presumably we
communicate a little bit to find this
cut this meaningful cut
okay
then we proceed recursively that like um
i think so but i i mean
the number of rounds will still be
square root of i times c i think that's
the problem i mean you will not save the
number of rounds you will just save on
the amount of communication in each
round and this is the
but maybe i didn't get it you can take
it off and yes
yes
could you go back so what
the
financial efficiency of your protocol
so
so uh in each round we pay this many
bits
and the number of rounds since in each
round
yeah so there's another factor of
entropy internal entropy so we get an
internal entropy square times log log
cc
is
just entropy times log
exactly yes